hi guys it's self arete again with
another episode of the tutorial series
and today I'm gonna have to do something
which I am not too good at and yes I
must be honest I'm going to
procrastinate this and it's the queue
line but for this coaster I guess it's
my lucky day because I'm just going to
do a very simple queue line because this
is a simple coaster but I'll explain
more about that later on when I have
some time on my hands first of all I
always want to start out with a small
square at least in this case it's a
square but basically I'm gonna do a zig
zaggy kind of queue line so right now
this may not look like anything but I'm
just gonna place these round things on
the side and then you'll probably see
what kind of shape this queue line is
going to take it's going to be that one
very simple but effective and
space-saving queue line because you know
in many cases a queue line is actually
part of the ride itself you know you're
going to have to spend a lot of time in
the queue line and you're gonna wonder
their guests to be entertained in the
queue line and you can use the queue
line to you know set the mood and
ambience for the rollercoaster but since
this is just a simple generic
rollercoaster I don't really need to do
any of those things and I can't because
I don't have the available space for
buildings and scenery and stuff like
that so I'm just going to do a very
simple but somewhat effective to queue
line also I'm going to leave out the
Fastpass part of the queue line but you
can also add a Fastpass and if you don't
know where the fastballs line is it's
like you can buy a ticket to skip all of
the lines of the rides and that means
that you do need to make one extra queue
line which is a shorter queue line and a
more simple queue line but this is for
all the people who like spend extra
money to be able to skip the lines which
some people don't like that but it's a
thing that happens especially I think in
six like spikes and parts like that
basically we've got really big rides or
very popular attractions that many
people want to go in you can you can pay
extra money to skip them to skip the
queue it's but it yeah it's when you
think about it it's a really weird
strategy but of course it does give the
onus with the park a lot more money now
I want to add some borders on the side
of these on the sides of these paths
simply because yeah it's just it just
looks a lot better or not I think these
board isn't quite doing it but yeah okay
is it's not too bad but yeah you can
basically use any wall set for this like
shyguys planters or shyguy splendors 2
will work fine as well station gyms
fencing is a great set for stuff like
this I'm just using this set because I
just like this texture right now really
you can use any set for this as long as
it's a as it's a low small wall that can
serve as a border for the path covers
because normally in real life you'd
either have fences with borders like
these or you'd have sent or something or
like a gravel path which does not really
have a border at all but you don't have
to do it like that in this game you
can't have a texture that slowly fades
out into the grass but so we we need to
add borders so I want to add borders in
here as well and now you can really see
the shape of the cue line where you have
that signature zigzag thing just a safe
space now what you can also do what I
might probably also do is add some small
rope fences over here so that if it's
really quiet and there's barely anyone
in the park you can open up these ropes
that people don't have to walk through
this entire fence wait that's actually a
good idea I'm actually going to do that
going to remove all this sorry to that
then but that's just a general good idea
yet to do so just going to do this and
get the half ball okay that's all good
and then a sonic spike
all right no this all looks good and
fine but let's see okay the leg is real
though let's check out that's been
around no that doesn't help much in
general if you have like which I am way
too use to at this point you can like
point the camera towards that to which
that part of the park when there's no
scenery and you generally have less leg
but I see that the leg is currently
generated by fraps so that doesn't help
too much in any case I need to play some
more Pathak office in here right one two
and three and four and now I don't
exactly know if I still have these rope
or rope fences which I probably don't
even have anymore that that would be a
shame in any case I need to check which
kind of fences I want to use I think I'm
going to use Station Jim's fencing
because that Sanchez has very detailed
fences and I really like the look of it
plus you can you can choose three colors
so it's a pretty flexible set and what I
sometimes like to do is just hint at the
colors of the rollercoaster in the fence
of the cue line so for example the
rollercoaster is that turquoise color
then I'm gonna hint at that in the fence
you don't necessarily have to do that
and many parks don't do it most of his
time there are fences of their cue line
to match the theme though but in this
case since this is a generic coaster I
just like doing it I just think it looks
pretty cool and for these small curves I
think there's yeah lie is a problem
there's no half curve in this part of
the set I think only this one has a half
curve oh well that's stupid
well then hmm we're gonna have to work
around that later on that's one
disadvantage of this set I don't know if
you forgot about those pieces or not but
it's just a bit annoying right now for
this small gap over here I'm gonna need
to use a different set simply because
there's no small curved fence in that
sat so I feel like shyguys planters is
probably the best way to go in this case
you can also just use shyguy splendors
for the entire cube I just don't like
the set you know for that it's a little
bit less detailed than that so she jumps
out holy [ __ ] that leg though I'm still
that like is going on even though I've
got enough hard drive space left and I'm
not running anything in the background
which is very annoying and I've tried
multiple times of multiple days but just
keeps lagging right now for the fences
that can open and close I think I'm
gonna use some cloth fences so T for
LSAT has stuff like that in it this one
you can take the cloth one edge well not
the conform one probably
well that might actually work though but
I think I'm gonna use the regular one
now yeah I'm gonna use the regular one
because I want to build it myself
okay come on mate
now I'm gonna use this mm it might be
your no need to use this everywhere yeah
I'm probably going to use it in every
one of these things let's see I know not
exactly know what the best idea is for
is is for this well I'm and then I'm
gonna use these posts that you can use
to in like either get the cloth out
there or not if there's nobody in the
park and you want guests to go to the
station really quick and then for the
rest of that thing I'm just gonna place
these everywhere and probably remove
those fences in the middle because the
space in there is a bit tight well let's
see then place this that should be about
it
and remove that one let's see I think
that's good enough kind of wait no that
is really cramped though so I'm probably
gonna want to remove all these things
and actually make it as wide as the
other fence iqs so more like this then
yeah that should actually be a bit
better also I'm gonna recolor these
things because there's too much blue
going on at some point it's just not
good anymore I guess let's see and open
that side again then all I have to do in
the end it's just play some more borders
over here and then I think I'm pretty
much done when it comes to fencing and
I'm using cloth right now
you can use any fence type that you can
remove for example you like fences that
can open like a gate or something not a
big gate like this but yeah whatever
basically now let's see take the posts
again I think I'm gonna color the posts
blue though because they interact with
the fences right now that's not seems
pretty decent to me um no I just in the
end you might also add some more cue
line fences but I'll talk about that in
a minute first I need to finish these
borders let's see I always just use the
full borders but you can also use the
conform borders the only problem with
conforming pieces is that they don't
that they don't go in the half or
quarter tiles and full pieces actually
do so in some cases this might be
handier now for the cue line fences I
always open up Costa Jose pathway extent
extent know what no coast of Costa Jose
queue line fences holy [ __ ] and just
because you know it looks pretty cool
line it just prevents the cue line from
turning into a chaos going to make them
gray though because otherwise there's so
much blue going on like a bit of hinting
at the colors of the coaster is cool but
too much and it just starts to get too
much basically and I think I'm just
gonna yeah I'll take these straight ones
oh and don't worry about these sharp
things sticking out you can always add
some more poles but I always do their
poles in the end just to save time right
and then this also makes a good fence
for the whatever you call them again
I just forgot okay just gonna add these
in the middle everywhere except for the
beginning and the end of this little
shortcut and use quarter pieces for
their curves
okay that looks good now I think I used
a yeah I used two wrong piece for this
kind of and now I'm going to have to
place the poles in um it's this is a
good placing no it isn't damn
where was the good placement again oh
yeah the normal pole right and I'm just
gonna built these in the end because you
don't really need them in other places
this thing supports itself pretty much
well enough and then there's only one
thing left to do I think